what's up kids family it's your boy
meech here back again with another
episode of our debate show
sneaker swap where we argue a lot
today i have here with me season
solidano christian pierre
jeff johnson how are we doing today guys
doing good oh we have another little mic
situation guys but we're doing really
really awesome today
um the topic for today is if you had the
kobe 5 bruce lee
would you trade it for the kobe 6
grinch's uh
does anybody want to take take first go
here
yeah yeah i can do it i could go first
rock out christian
yeah i'm trading for the kobe 6 branches
i'm taking the greatest
christmas day sneaker of all time the
grinch's other sneakers are actually
really put uh christmas day kicks on the
map to be honest and like
i think that's what basically had other
signature athletes come correct for this
day and moving forward so
and to be honest i don't think there's
like a better shoe like the grinch shoe
for
someone like kobe someone who really
relished being the villain being like
the enemy people love to hate
so like i thought it was great marketing
on both his part
nike's part of the whole team i thought
it was amazing and just
you guys don't remember i must have a
scene for you real quick like
it's 2010 back to back finals mvp
uh the big three of braun d-wade
chris bosh coming into la a staples
center for christmas day
that matchup he knew he was ready for
that you knew everybody was ready for
that game
so he had to come correct and now he had
to come quick with that and they blessed
them with
uh with those grinch colorways so that
was amazing to see
and uh yeah i'm definitely taking those
three inch colorways over uh
the bruce lee and that's a beautiful
it's a perfect colorway too okay
follow up cj jeff what's going on
yeah i mean christian stole everything i
was gonna say
i know i think it's obviously the grinch
the grinch colorway
uh was probably the peak of christmas
day sneakers
because after that i feel like nike took
some interpretations on what christmas
was and
sometimes just didn't even make green or
red like to me christmas sneaker green
or red
but it was just like the moment where
you're getting a kobe and lebron both
still in their primes playing on
christmas day like
i hope basketball still looks like that
when we hit this next christmas like
i just uh that moment
with the grinches and obviously the
bruce lee's like that encapsulates you
know the mama mentality really well
but we've seen so many other iterations
of bruce lee colorways on all sneakers
you know with
obviously it's you know like the kobe
and kyrie collab but
i feel like nothing has ever beat uh you
know
this on a christmas day sneaker and also
on like a pop culture collab
so i gotta say i would trade my kobe uh
bruce lee's
for some thank you grinch's you for that
chef talk to me kit all right it's more
bruce lee for me then
because i'm not keeping i'm keeping it
first off
um he you talk about getting into
the villain role this encapsulates
the mamba mentality he literally became
the black mamba
and transformed into a shoe going off of
greatest martial artist of all time
bruce lee and one of the dopest
martial arts flick series in kill bill
but one and two like he was like
a literal sneaker assassin when he put
those on and he already had that
mentality from
jump and when you look at the sneaker
for me it tells that story
you can see the like the slashes the red
slashes with the black and gold it just
looks
regal it looks like when he's wearing
those
he's killing everything and and and he's
leaving nothing in his wake and that's
the type of
literal mamba mentality that he had and
i
trust me i love the grinches i love all
the the christmas sneakers
i the braun eight christmases are one of
my favorites and and
i don't know like for me they're up
there in in christmas sneaker i
one one and two one one a whatever the
case may be
and then we could talk about the
christmas sb dunks that that that
come out like there's a lot of dope
christmas colorways out there
and for me just in terms of what i would
wear
i'd wear both for sure but those bruce
lee's
just mean something more to me because i
feel like
the grinch is probably more of real life
kobe
mentality but the bruce lee is
his on-court character manifested in a
sneaker one real cool thing jeff you
just mentioned with the lebron eight
christmas colorway
it's also kind of a crazy experience
that that the grinches
went against the the lebron eight like
the same day
same game everything like all both of
the corn the same exact time like
and for like those two shoes be one of
the best christmas colorways that we've
seen that happened like a decade ago
it's kind of crazy to think about
yeah it was they was nike was like 82-0
that year
2010 they just went off it was like
you'll leave everybody else
alone please yeah and you guys talked
about you know kobe being the villain in
the literal grinch it was what the first
time we were seeing that big three heat
in a christmas day game against
kobe like to have a shoe that
totally is like to make that statement i
am the villain i am here to stop
everyone's good
time is perfect despite the heat beating
the lakers that day right but i just
love how
kobe was never afraid to assume those
roles you know and find kind of like a
theme
or a storyline that existed out there
and goes here's what i'm tapping into
i'm gonna drop 30. um and so whether or
not they won or uh one or not
it was just cool that kobe always
attached himself to that stuff
yeah nobody nobody really remembers if
he won or lost that game it was just
like the moment of all you mentioned
like the
big three coming together their first
year going to staples center like
and like this is prime copy everybody's
waiting for this game right so
it was a dope thing especially the
lakers organization or nike or whoever
did it like giving
a lot of the pairs to the people who
were at the game nice little
touch so so i love you guys taking this
conversation commemorating kobe
i think that uh his impact on the game
from
basketball point and the sneakers point
goes beyond you know what we can put
into words
nike's given nike has given us a week to
celebrate
kobe mamba week uh they're dropping five
colorways
of the pro tro this is the first time
the five is getting the protra
uh we're getting a big stage colorway
five-time champ colorway
undefeated what if pack and a girls uh
by
e-y-b-l colorway have
you guys seen this what are your
thoughts and let me know what do you
think about uh the upcoming mama movie
i know i need that shannon sharp
treatment i need a van
i need a kobe undefeated van pulling up
to my house
my phone ready to just record a dude
popping out of the sliding door
like that is straight out of a movie and
who better
than shannon sharp uh in his his
reaction to get it but like
i want to see more of those i want to be
on the list
uh again yeah just that that is the
dream
for a sneaker head as a kobe fan as a
laker fan as a basketball fan
for people to roll to my house in these
like all-terrain vehicles
bringing out you know these just like
sacred kicks
in crazy packages that that was awesome
to me
cj and you know i think you deserve it
man not only do you have this sweater on
824 number two not only do you have the
hat on
you know yellow and purple don't trip
but the mic
cover being yeah i tried it i switched
it out i had this
wow i switched it out i was like you
know it's a special episode that's
the perfect story i actually really
appreciate it and i got those
appropriate what they did for mambo week
um like personally i was like really
curious what was going to look like
because like i wanted to celebrate
myself for mom with and what did that
look like so
i think the colorways that they had like
are the perfect ones to have i think
they had like
they had a big stage colorway which kind
of like um
celebrates the 10-year anniversary for i
guess his fifth trip
another colorway that celebrates like i
think all of the championships together
and i think
obviously the undefeated collab like we
didn't know what that's about
yeah we were going to talk about that
and the uibl one is cool too because
like
it shows all because like as we all know
like kobe was really big into like youth
sports women's sports and
women women hoops in general so like
that really encapsulated the whole thing
for me um
and i think one other thing obviously
not a sneaker but that jersey that
jersey is clean
that that black jersey um and i i didn't
know at first but he actually like
co-designed that jersey so that's a nice
little touch to it and it has like the
m like the snake mamba print i think on
the jersey too like obama so like
that's great um i just can't wait for
next i can't wait for that to try to cop
all of them to be honest
or try to get it at least yeah that
jersey is the
crown jewel of the whole collection to
me i'm not even a laker fan and i think
that's
that jersey is hard you know it's
it's what you would it it should be like
the
number one thing any laker fan wants to
cop if especially any kobe fan wants to
cop too
um it's still nuts that were talking
about him in the past ten years
i'm hot i'm sorry like that there's
still it's still
bugged out that he's gone
and it's just you know i think if you're
gonna if you're gonna celebrate him if
you're gonna honor his legacy
those colorways all target different
parts
of his career and his life and just who
he was as a basketball
player through the sneakers um i don't
know if i'm gonna be able to cop him
but uh you know it's it's
i like all the colorways are dope to me
the the jerseys fire and i i hope
the real fans get an opportunity to get
up here uh
can we can we talk about that real quick
of
obviously you know he just passed
recently and i think everyone was sort
of
you know confused as to how nike would
proceed with releasing this stuff
i don't know i don't know if i can
prepare myself to feel when i see this
stuff
on resale on the apps on auction and
everything and it's selling for crazy
price like
what are you doing with the the profit
there like are the real fans getting it
so
i haven't heard anything on numbers for
these packs but
like you said i hope real fans get it
and i hope resellers
can just look into their heart and be
like realize what you're doing here
profiting off of a a legend's death like
i i you know you can't tell anyone
everyone
what to do and you know be morally right
here but
yeah it's worrisome that the game can
get like that
right it's tough cj because like
obviously when he passed
um a lot of his shoes kind of just like
just went up in price like we sellers
you know what i mean
and like shout outs at least the brands
who were or like the boutiques or
whoever it was like kind of just like
not
kind of reeling that back and like
canceling all orders and stuff like that
or like
i think i might i think some like um
sites like go in stock kicks kind of
like going reverting back to the
original prices before he passed you
know what i mean so like
it's going to be weird it's going to be
weird to see how people are going to
plan on that because like obviously
if people don't get people are going to
want to try to get them you know what i
mean like that's just only natural
but like the price that they set it at
is going to be pretty important to see
so i don't know who were some of those
guys
uh that you really feel like you know
are the heir to kobe's throne
you know like that can really carry the
mantle of the mama guys or girls you
know because i think sabrina is another
person that we really need to discuss as
well so one thing i think
we may have spoke about before but i
don't even know is like a lot of these
dudes
the devin brokers anthony davis
sabrina like you just mentioned or even
like i think darren fox like he just
loves wearing clothes as well
it'd be it'd be amazing to see if like
similar to jordan
similar to i guess even wade or i guess
like we see with steph now as like
having our own kobe line right having
kobe having his own
line and having these guys kind of being
the dudes underneath it who idolized him
right
it'd be it'd be amazing to see i don't
know like a naggy
devin kobe different booker one or
whatever however how how that sounds or
looks or
you know i think it'd be great for those
dudes and um
because i think they all follow this
path follow this game you know i mean
there's a lot of parts from this game
and like
you definitely see it on their shoes and
their sneakers so it'd be great to see
those guys kind of fall in that mental
and kind of honor the legacy continuing
can we build that list right now who who
do you guys think like really
really belongs up there i mean if it's
just nike
it it would be like um i think tate will
be part of his jordan but because nike's
just dianna fox i think it's
anthony davis devin booker sabrina for
sure
sabrina and diane fox i think it's just
those four five guys we're fighting
girls
that's arena team kobe we need to make
it happen i do love
i do love that idea christian and then
following off of that
uh you know team kobe but i really just
want to talk about kobe
and his signature line uh as being one
of the best honestly uh what kobe's on
uh 10 10 well there's like there's like
i think one to eleven i think the last
game was elevens
and then yeah in the 80s yeah all those
like like few of those
that have where do you guys think kobe
signature line stacks up against you
know michael jordan lebron
uh kevin durant i almost don't
it's like in its own category because
i've never seen as many chances
taken in a line than in kobe's just
the whole low top thing is
like revolutionary like
we see we were talking about this in a
previous episode but the giannises the
kds the pgs
those all don't look the way they look
now unless kobe
made that like i want my shoe to be like
a soccer cleat i want it to be low-cut
because man how many people on the
courts for decades were like i can only
play in high tops
and that just like pretty much debunking
that myth
and then for the next 10 years and for
you know from seeing this giannis line
that just launched in the pg's
we are probably on it that is the new
that is the normal i want to say new
normal but that has been the normal
because of kobe's line and i don't think
the jordans or any of these other
uh lines i've ever had an impact like
that i think
that three to the four cj from like that
waffle
kind of style on the three to the left
of the fourth that's like most pivotal
part of his line
yeah period like the like my favorites
are like just to say between the four
and the eight
those those four signature shoes those
are amazing
i think and like to your point it's up
echelon almost revolutionary you know to
the point like to do that and that's
what makes one
i guess i think makes it sneaker was
lying like
besides mj the best one you know what i
mean um and
and what makes it to me the best one of
the best is just because
i think everybody mentions about lebron
no one's really like six eight six nine
250
and like where can wear that kind of
high top of his shoe like that
but with kobe's shoes you'll see guys
like a whole bunch of guards play in it
you'll see bigs like 80d like i
mentioned before playing it you'll see
like different playing styles be able to
wear and be flexible accustomed to that
shoe
i think that's what kind of like also
makes this shoe like
one of the best i think it's the most
innovative
if you think about when those kobe 4s
dropped this was probably at the advent
of positionless basketball
when we just started to have that
concept to think of
oh my god are we no longer going to have
centers
are they just going to be bigs and and
the fact that
even when you're drafting in fantasy
basketball you got to ask the question
is he considered a guard or is he
considered a forward is he you know is
he a three or four or five
like he literally dismantled we
dismantled the numbers and positionless
basketball
is a thing but he created a shoe
going low top innovating with those
um with the world football cleats and
and that technology he made it so that
future players like an ad like a giannis
who could be
610 plus and move like a guard had a
shoe to complement them
so it's it it literally transcends
position
because back in the day if guards had a
certain type of shoe
big men had a certain type of shoe it
had for the support
for the for the um the weight of it uh
the mobility it had all of those these
this
shoe is like a positionless basketball
shoe
so i think in terms of that in terms of
the style
and really for for on-court performance
too
i think it just it does stand on its own
i yeah i also want to talk about too i
i haven't seen a line since jordan have
marketing the same way or as close to
jordan
except for kobe like i don't see lebron
nike commercials for the shoes
specifically much anymore
but man i can off the top of my head
just name like the kobe system with
kanye like that's a legendary commercial
or when he teamed up with the jackass
crew and he was jumping over the car
you know and like where is lebron how
come lebron giannis uh pg
kd they're not doing commercials like
that so and i don't know if that was
kobe being you know
he's in la like he's a you know producer
writer director type
but i miss that and i think kobe
took that task you know he could have
saw the pressure of jordan be like
man i can't have that all around
marketing like performance shoe whatever
all this stuff
but he took in his own hands and he has
some legendary commercials and marketing
that
haven't been beat to to this date yeah i
think they left i think they leveraged
the fact that they're all walking
billboard ads now yeah and with social
media
and with the way in which we're we're on
our phones and
and we're on multiple screens it's
almost like they don't
have to go as hard but
honoring the the craft of marketing and
and
wanting to literally make everything a
movie that's something to be commended
because you can
have basic commercials here's the new
lebron here's the new giannis
but you want to make indelible content
that's going to resonate with your fans
and resonate with sneakerheads
and people anyone who likes a good
commercial likes good content
forever and those are the type of things
like kobe system is something i'll never
forget yeah
because it was just so catchy just like
i'll never forget the nike basketball
commercial when they recreated the beat
with dribbling
i'll never forget that that's just
something that left its mark was
innovative at the time and was just was
just
dope and it leaves an impression so i
think that the
the new stars are gonna have to figure
out however in their way to leave those
same impressions and jeff we need that
right because that really really extends
the lifespan of the shoe like we're
talking about you know it gives people
an opportunity to get those nostalgia
moments ten years down the line you know
there's
there's the penny commercials there's
the kobe system commercials there's
jordan's commercials
um we have a couple of good lebron ones
but for the most part you know a lot of
these
guys haven't really gave me an iconic
commercial you know
am i gonna i there's so many times where
we tie back those sneaker moments to
those commercials and you know it makes
me want to cop in the near future
it could really hurt but think i'm
thankful that kobe took care of those
chances man
even the commercial where he uh he
jumped over the car
yeah nuts of that brother i mean that
was like
viral videos you know before viola verde
videos that was house of highlights
before house of habits existed
you know like he would he had that he
was that forward thinking where he knew
it should be shot this way it kind of be
like believable
but also it was kind of dangerous too
because kids were like can i jump over a
car can i put on these guys
it is it's putting that danger of like
well these shoes make me jump higher
uh and i think that's part of that's
just like brilliant marketing
to kind of just like give that
inspiration that just enable
kids to feel like their favorite athlete
the one other commercial that i
i love i love this um the car commercial
the another one
that um that i was thinking about was
the one him and lebron
that was a great one too those are great
we need that we need
nike to like because they got
inspirational motivational
down but yeah just something about
nike's just like
like comedic commercials they sold shoes
they again it was like it made it
the shoe itself was a conversation piece
and so were those commercials and they
were airing during those epic matchups
christmas day like finals and all that
that was just all part of the package
back to you know growing up and loving
basketball
one thing i got to say also one thing
about also kobe's line is like
his impact with nike was so strong that
i don't
ever released but you guys remember that
uh easy two kobe colorway that they had
leaked before
like the fact that he had an impact and
obviously the commercial that they were
working together and just that shoe in
general is so rare to see
like one of the like quiet i don't even
be quiet it's one of the grails of like
the sneaker world
and we talked about the kobe 5s the
bruce lee we talked about the drenches
but what is your favorite kobe of all
time
i'd love to go first um
for
for me the kobe 9 elite man the high top
red joints
at the time it was just so it was so
innovative it was so different like
he was we were rocking the kobe lows for
the low kobe's for so so long
um and then we get the high in the and
in the red too that red was such a bold
statement
i love that shoe i wish i could have got
my hands on that shoe i still
need to get my hands on that [ __ ] but
like that's the kobe that really did it
for me all together hope they can just
help me do whatever he wants man
this guy's gonna put any shoe out i'll
purchase it and that was the one for me
that's tough that's tough last time
before my favorites
between the four and the eight i
want to say my favorite might be
the galaxy sevens oh
galaxy seven is gonna be my favorite one
the ridges are like might be there too
but
i think the galaxy sevens are my
favorite kobe yeah
mine are the grinches but my
i don't know if this counts but when he
was a secret free agent and all the
brands were ruining them
i thought nike won when they gave him
the harachi's because again it showed
like
that they knew who they were dealing
with a guy who who knew basketball who
respected basketball culture
and gave those arachi's kobe played in
them in that purple and yellow colorway
um and you know it just that's the shoe
that pops my head when i remember that
time
and yeah i mean i know they're not
kobe's but i mean i guess when he when
he then got his line
he had the harachi technology he was the
one who brought that back
in the 2k fives uh or was it 2k for i
forget what which ones they were but
yeah i think those those kobe pe
harachi's are like my
second favorite kind of non-technical
kobes yeah for me
i would say really the two that we're
debating now the bruce lee and the
grinch's
are the two that i think of when i think
about kobe sneakers off rip like i legit
bought kobe basketball shorts because of
the kobe
bruce lee because the black and gold
shorts with them
like i bought those shorts because i
love that colorway
and um you know those two shoes to me
are like
two of the most iconic colorways that he
has
and just even like the like the grinches
are hard to beat i ain't gonna hold you
like those are just
they just look good it looks like uh a
reptile
put on a christmas fit and it went to
gold play basketball you know what i
mean in the best way possible
um i i just love i love those two
the nine elites they weren't my thing
but they just looked different
it felt like it it felt like you were
wearing
rain rain boots or whatever like what do
they call them galoshes
it looked like galoshes that you could
hoop in but it's just futuristic too
like i didn't even understand it but it
was something like
if i wanted to have them as a part of a
collection
i would do that and and and to your
point cj those hirachi's i love haraches
so when he came out with those i was
like oh he's fooling right now
he's on he's on his whole different way
and i love how we we calmly forget about
his adidas line
so you know even moving i know i know
it's like
voldemort right now but uh yeah
yeah i guess so i was gonna say real
quick his free asian year that sneaker
fishing was one of the most swagged out
sneakers he brought out
like the kobe 3's i'm sorry the jordan
threes he wrote out the eights he
brought out like he's wearing like
flint's like
french blue like it was it was wild
seeing all those shoes they're like okay
when you're making another brand turn
your other players signature shoes into
lakers colorways
yeah you are one of the goats you
deserve to be in the goat conversation
iversons he had irises turn into like
your colorways too and like i was like
right after i guess they beat the what
the six it was
it was too close to them beating the
sixers in the finals for that to happen
i would love to hear from you guys uh
you know a defining moment
uh of colby in your life and how he's
impacted you
one of the great things that you could
see from kobe is just like
it's obviously like determination will
and all that but also to the fact that
he was how many how many years do you
play in the league what almost 20 years
in the league
and like be able to switch from one
passion to another and still being able
to bring that same kind of dedication
and the determination of
himself saying before and into that so
like you don't have to
have your your your mind and your heart
set on just one thing you have multiple
things towards you and just bringing
that
onto your next stage or career i went to
go see them
in the the in 2013 at the garden when
they were playing the knicks
and something just told me yo i never
saw kobe play
in real life like live so i said yo i
want to go i want to go in
and um go see him and and see see what
it's about like experience it for myself
and i remember i never forget it the
knicks were
killing them and then melo got hurt and
it was one of those times where
it was it was like the fourth quarter it
was like the fourth quarter and you know
it's like 18-point lead or something
like that and you're like okay
everybody just keeps it whatever and you
know they'll go into a win
and this man did not want to go quietly
into the night
and he just starts you just look up the
game he turned up with like his own like
8-0 run or something hitting
hitting threes going going off and you
know the knicks were able to hold them
off
but it was just anybody else
could have folded and said all right you
know this is a game on the road whatever
we'll
we got a long road trip ahead we'll
we'll
uh we'll chalk it up but you could tell
it felt like every moment was a big
moment for him he wanted to win every
game and then going to the garden and
wanting to turn up
it was just it literally was like that
mentality flipped
for me and it just kind of when you see
greatness
with your own two eyes like live in
person
tangibly and not on a screen
it feels different it's a different mood
it's a different vibe
and watching his greatness and seeing
his never quit mentality and just the
fact that he wanted that win even though
all intents and purposes the game was
over it just it just put another idea
about how i can attack life and how i
can approach
certain insurmountable odds yeah for me
it was i mean there was two moments one
that everyone knows is the
you know the achilles tearing the
achilles and then still shooting the
free throws and
it was that moment and then him yeah
like post uh
press conference just being like just
like it kind of made
kobe feel like all of us it's like it
sucks it wasn't like
this crazy speech it was like it sucks
but i'ma come back and so that was one
moment but
i my high school in the mid 90s i wasn't
going there at the time but
they played kobe uh for the state champ
the pennsylvania state championship
and i just heard a little bit about kobe
but then watching that state
championship game
my high school versus laura marion and
then they were just running packages
like they already knew he was gonna be
this star but the fact that it was
happening to my small town that no
famous people ever had any like
connection to
and then seeing him you know at halftime
then being like this kid might go to the
nba
and then go to the nba and then you know
not have that great of a rookie year and
then go and play an all-star game and
play jordan one-on-one
like specifically like intentional and
it was like to see
someone who kind of touched something
that was you know
tangible in my life to then go and play
against jordan and then even just
reach those accolades it was like wow
like that
i've never experienced a person to pass
through
you know sort of my life personally and
then touch everyone else's
and cj i'm i'm gonna take it uh and
expand on there for you because i
i'm really the same way you know we
watch this guy come in at 17
into the league you know to one of the
greatest franchises in sports
uh come in work under you know a
superstar in shaq
get his opportunity to contribute in the
finals you know for three you know back
to back to back years
ascend himself into that upper echelon
of players right now that
team shifts around him you know they
start losing some games but
through all that like he doesn't lose
that mama mentality that drive to win
you know that drive to succeed and be
the best
fight through a couple more years you
know works his way back to the top
he's fighting through uh dislocated
fingers achilles all that gets two more
chips with pow
um and really revives the city of la
right and then like
it's so beautiful to see that like it
really taught me like not to really ever
give up
you know like there's a lot of times
that he could have been like yo i'm out
of here man i think i gave you guys 15
years i gave you guys 70 years
but he always worked through that
because he always knew he had something
bigger in mind
and then you know he takes that passion
from
basketball game and puts it into his
family into his daughters into
you know the next youth of basketball